so briefly just introducing who we are
my name's John I'm working in the safety
investigation Center at Cranfield
University we celebrated 40 years of
teaching accident vestigation so it's
own airport is actually Embry Riddle in
the u.s. in other areas basic focus to
university so we do a lot of very cool
stuff for aerospace so what I'm talking
about today is about precision touchdown
one exactly why and where the aircraft
touchdown
well why do I know this it's because
sometimes stuff goes wrong this was a
flight and care the way I was coming in
it was a little bit higher on the
approach it landed deep it was raining
it was wet and they just didn't stop in
time and they ran off the end of the
runway dunno no casualties it was all
really straightforward but it's just
it's an example of what can go wrong if
you if stuff goes wrong and in order to
improve I understanding of how to avoid
stuff like that happen in the future and
worse incidents we need to have better
understanding about how often people
land where they intend to land and as
I'll try to explain we don't have as
good a grasp on that as you might think
we have good understanding where as
you've heard may have heard from the
last speaker about where galaxies are
and how far they are but something
simple as we're in aircraft touchdown
exactly on the runway is actually a
little bit more elusive so what we do
with in large still air transport is we
have what's called a safety management
system where we try to identify all the
hazards we've got we try to parse out
which the most important we try to find
some way to control them to mind to them
and just to reiterate to verify and
continually improve the safety of
organization this often involves large
amounts of simulator time for the pilots
and so what we'd like to do is we'd like
to create realistic scenarios that could
help them actually improve in something
good actually going to happen or is more
critical if you may remember a couple
years ago we had the milk on the Hudson
that was a pilot who was actually on his
own time doing simulator training we're
just that kind of instant and that's the
kind of benefit you can have if you can
target the kind of incidents that
actually going to crop up so being able
to understand exactly
what's going on dear statistics about
the various factors that are going into
the cause of them can really help in
terms of improving safety within the
organization so imma walk off as you
might expect we have a ton of sensors I
mean literally there is more than a ton
of sensors we have the airspeed we have
all the various flight controls we have
the angle of the flaps we have the angle
of the arrow on the angle of the tail
the rudder all of its monitored normally
it's logged at the same rate and it all
comes to the system so you have what's
called a def down or D mu which is a
digital flight data acquisition unit or
data module unit and then goes into one
or two places it goes into what you may
have heard of before at the black box
it's the orange one it's the fight
engine corner and also what's called a
QAR it's a quick extra school quick
access recorder now the Cuellar is what
we actually spend more of our time with
physically flights someone will go out
and die kidding up with the USB stick or
sometimes it's a legacy serial cable why
you might hire or veil printer and
sometimes and I prefer not but sometimes
wireless or Bluetooth and they will
download the data from the last couple
of flights so we can log into the system
so it's all has to go to the aircraft
and touch it but we can get the data out
on a reason regular basis so we can log
it and we can put into the system or we
would if it wasn't all in binary most
you'll probably recognize hexadecimal
which is based on the understanding
you've translated 8-bit bytes into hex
code which is however I'm showing you
hexadecimal but it's completely
irrelevant because actually flight data
recorders called rich national standard
recording 4-bit words just you know to
be helpful so we have to go from this 12
bit word format it's a fixed frame data
layout and because we're trying to be
efficient and it comes from the days
when 8-bit was a big thing you know
having a different there was interleaved
so you'll have the most difficult it's
from one variable overlapping with the
least of different bits of another
variable which can cause weird artifacts
but if you have some system and
there are various different ways you can
go from this binary data as long as you
have what's called air the forever felt
a logical flame layout we you're being
told within that fixed frame where all
the variables are what they aren't mean
and how to translate them from their
binary representation into an
engineering unit then you get a CSV file
out of it
some people will sadly have to depend
upon systems that still run Windows 3.1
this is very sad but you know this is
the future with Python someday I might
actually be able to do it if it wasn't
all copyrighted so that sadly is
something I'll have to remain currently
in the dark ages but once we get the
data out because you start doing useful
things with it it's not really big data
in the sense you might think is we've
got a dataset at cranville which is
about ten years of a major domestic
carrier so that's about 18 terabytes
it's it's a reasonable chunk of data it
takes a while to do stuff with it but
it's not big data in the sense that
you're probably more familiar with but
so we do have some problems and that's a
most of us aerospace engineers we can go
into great detail about the dynamics of
the aircraft and the speed and things
like compressibility effects and where
the wings structurally sound enough and
it's a maintenance being done but it
turns a pro going we're really more fond
of MATLAB and indeed my PhD was done
almost entirely and MATLAB and it's a
wonderful tool but it really isn't quite
as flexible as you might want so we're
about two years ago ice touch Python for
the first time and it's been an
adventure I have to say absolutely
fantastic it's just seeing what we can
actually do with this stuff so it's I've
put down there that it's exploring
versus processing and python has been
much more useful the magnet has been for
that particular type of thing where I'm
doing spending more time exploring the
data that I am actually doing widget
computation so this is what flight data
looks like when you've actually got it
out this is what is a missed approach so
the aircrafts going around and they've
decided actually they're one of the
engineer today so they're climbing a bit
more up turnaround coming back it's
almost incomprehensible
it's just so many different lines
overlaid there is an access but I've
just left it off just to kind of show
you what's actually happening in terms
of the thing that is important within
flight data is the relationship of one
variable to another one place on its own
is almost irrelevant what you need to
know is the stuff like the speed in
relation to the after in relation to the
temperature outside so you can get to
you find out what the reynolds number is
so you can get what the air density was
which will tell you something about the
flight properties of the aircraft so
it's very contextual and these are some
of the continuous variables we actually
have a lot of logical variables as well
and all of them are boolean some of them
have three four five logical states the
undercarriage is one particular example
because you might have undercarriage
down undercoat down and locked
undercarriage coming up undercarriage
stowed and the coats going down these
are all logical values that also stored
in the flight data so working out where
touchdown happened we could be
reasonably certain about when it
happened so this is some accelerometer
data from an aircraft as an example but
it's the normal acceleration which is
the one you might know essentially with
gravity which is why you can see that
the blue line is based around one
because it's normal earth gravity and
then the red line is long - too much has
fallen aft as you can see there's two
major areas of interest on the red line
you can see there's a sudden spike in
positive long-term acceleration that's
when you get that pushed back into the
cities that about the aircraft
accelerate to take off and the other
side you can see is a negative spike
this is when it's breaking after landing
and around those two you'll get a lot of
activity in the normal acceleration quiz
you bumping up and as you go along the
runway and you also have this much
bigger spike when you land this is key
for us because we can look for that big
spike on landing after doing some stuff
to fill throughout the other portions of
the flight where it's there's just a bit
of turbulence or filtering our husbands
the white words actually this taxi after
landing that sort of thing but we can
actually find that but we do have
tilting because you can do these
artifacts in the data most of which are
due to the
of doing variable vaping because we only
have versions I have to space in the
flight data recorder in order to get
more laying out a very particular
variable typically they'll be wrapped so
when you come back to look at you have
to be careful and find out where they
wrapped it's not necessarily always
straightforward discovering that and
then also because you get interleaving
between different variables you
sometimes get to spurious things where
there's been a conversion here and we
can't get away from the moment because a
lot of this stuff is legacy systems that
as I mentioned self which still runs on
Windows 2.1 but we can eventually do and
get into pandas which makes everything
so much nicer on this no actually my
colleague did some stuff in art I could
use valency to find out how much time
pilots spend actually flying your hands
on the stick
and it turns out 495 percent at the time
they spend less than seven minutes in an
actual flight actually flying the
aircraft the rest of times the autopilot
and while I may have my own opinions
about which of those systems is safer
for flying the aircraft when interested
in the human experience here so if a
touchdown I've got this is what I wrote
a little thing to try and visualize from
the flight data what you have all the
touchdowns in my dataset for one
particular Airport which is Jersey I'll
go into white jersey in a minute but
this is using a library called geo
pandas which is absolutely fantastic I
highly recommend it there's a little was
all over myself called eros misty is
which is just about interrogating
OpenStreetMap using the over pine
library and constructing a structured
map of an airfield using that data so we
can then thought what's in there you'll
see I'm using the Shapley library as
well because I can then create these
pointer and then dew points versus other
points see if they're within certain
areas like with they're within the
taxiway where whether they're near the
runway doing an intersection of a
trajectory with a tax away one way you
can start to do really good operations
in terms of understanding the geometry
the reason I'm using Stapley instead of
rolling my own or doing something that's
more bespoke it's because the earth is
spherical
and it's not even nicely spherical so I
leave that to the geographers and they
can help me with their libraries so if I
just come over here so this is Jersey
this is OpenStreetMap with their fourth
inning and the folium library created
this map you can see this there's no
points plotted there and I haven't made
a mistake you can see just down the
bottom there's a little radio marker and
there's another little on there and if I
go up and zoom out I don't think that's
where the aircraft touchdown the problem
is the lettered launchers record in
what's called a short form to save space
because at the end of the day we know
they're they are off touchdown because
it's at that Airport so it obviously
touched out the wrong way and that in
the days when this was created it they
weren't really looking to do the masses
of touchdown locations for safety
reasons they were looking for where did
the aircraft fly in a kind of a gross
sense it was more the contextual where
they the aircraft head and what were the
accelerations which is why things like
the normal exciting have a much higher
data rate than latitude longs to but it
does hinder me in this particular piece
of research which is unfortunate
so this is the reason I chose Jersey on
the approach there was this very nice
little survey in the future as you come
out across the sea and then it goes up
over the dunes and then you get the
wrong way which means there's a
something like fantasy in match against
if I can do we construct the ground
track the ground - right under the air
of using what's called the radar
altimeter the radio altimeter is just a
it's a radio that sends a pulse down to
the earth and it gets a return and then
based on the profile of that return it
can guess how I do say guess how high
the aircraft is about the ground and by
looking at that and profiling all the
returns we get we can reconstruct the
terrain profile below the aircraft and
if we do some normalization by taking
the back to altitude of the aircraft
our first landed to give us our zero
then we can actually offset that at the
correct amount so that it matches up
against the true to aim and then by
translating it we can then do some
matching to work out how deep or short
the aircraft actually land on the runway
[Music]
this is what pilots are supposed to be
aiming for that they're not they don't
they have their own opinions it's called
the precision approach point indicated
it's a set of lights to show them from
very far away where they're supposed to
be aiming for and you can see there's
some white markers as well they're
physically quite large so you wouldn't
think pilots are able to miss them but
there we go
so this will really we report the date
again a select for the airport we've won
and clean it up to try move the
artifacts we're going to zero the radio
altimeter using the baron altitude of
the airport once we rounded the reading
we have to do that it's because it's
slightly over time a different slightly
different temperature slightly warm rain
humidity all these things can affect the
biomat altitude so you end up with it
offset by a couple of meters which just
ruins the whole effect once done that we
can fit a spline to the terrain and
radio I turn it to profile and then do
translations search to minimize the root
mean square error between those two
this is relatively simplistic but it's
just like it there and I just love it so
it makes so easy to do this bit it's
just still there because more difficult
and then once I've got a match I can
input the database and we can plot it
right see what you can see there is that
the black line is that the terrain
profiles created using the radio
altimeter data and then the blue line is
once it's actually fitted to the wheel -
right and you can see these red marker
is the expense of the runway this black
line is the where they're supposed to
have touchdown
the blue line is where in this instance
they'd actually touchdown and this is
the point in boquete which is also a
highly recommend if you want to have a
play around with data you just trying to
get sense for what's really happening I
used to use a lot of matplotlib but so I
was just converted by stuff like haven't
you seen we know that when you have very
old artifacts and when you're trying to
get the relationship you can link
different parts together that's just
absolutely fantastic so I really do
recommend the both a library and so this
is about 400 flights all overlaid and
you can see there's point these in the
good correlation between the flights
that we've been converting into this
spline and the excel terrain and aligned
so we could do some cure density
estimation i said no i will be doing
some code snippets for the wit so I
found the most fantastic from Python or
the most helpful not because they're the
most beautifully written code I thought
explain I'm an aerospace engineer but
just cuz I found them very useful for I
was doing and so this is matt baer code
density estimation and you can see we're
getting quite good agreement in terms of
where we're getting our returns versus
where the terrain axe tears and there's
always going to be gaps and holes
because that although the radio
altimeter is a continuous variable
that's being displayed to the parts in
real time it's not logged at that rate i
mean nothing in that set is logged at
over eight Hertz which will always give
you some offset between adjacent
data point so this is what I ended up
doing because I although I only do in
this particular instance on 219 flights
the full dataset is over 400,000 so I
had to do some power person you know I
found the multi press to librarian which
is built-in in Python 3 absolutely
fantastic I did playing a lot around
with a lot of different ones in Python
2.7 and I found one crossing was in the
end the easiest huge because I mean it's
just it's just two lines and most of
that was just packaging the inputs up so
that they iterate correctly and just yes
well of course all the ones I tried to
use it with so where I might use a for
loop to iterate over all the different
configurations all the different input
files I needed to do very similar
operations to and then spit out the
results somewhere because my files about
30 megabytes each I tended to pass a
temporary file a name to temporary file
using again another inbuilt library the
temp art library so that I could keep
all an area and the computer knows that
it can flush it all the way if it needs
to please just be home tab it meant I
could pass large metadata into this
without having to pass all on the phone
close just so I'm really just passing
the arguments and the file location not
everything in memory because even though
I know that's a bad idea but yeah it was
quite stay forward the reason is drunk
for not the actual function name was
because I did I used the partial library
to do the keyword argument separately
it's cool you can see a little bit
closer that we can expect lots of
logical stuff from the data as well
because it's using pandas these this is
actually the first of us ado this is
logical values I was talking about I was
trying to validate things like where
they turned off the taxiway and when
they're doing but the Dussehra
operations and why the landing D fall
along and what's actually happening here
is these two
little Yoda lines is when they deploy
the toast versus for some reason the
asymmetrically first one wing then the
other and then the next line is actually
where they stowed them back in so what
happens after you landed is the first
verses will pop out and help slow the
aircraft down because they're
redirecting the thrush so that you can
have more of a braking effect and then
when you don't need it anymore you don't
want to stop on the runway you want to
continue moving just enough you can tag
the off of the runway so they'll stow
the thought of us again so by looking at
where these happen relative to the
taxiways you can go actually yes that
looks like that was correct because the
officer
it matches the terrain quite nicely and
then also the aircraft leaves the
taxiway the correct location
you can see some uh stuff like here as
well that you've got velocity and you've
got altitude the reason why there's a
red and a green is because the red one
is the radio altimeter they've already
took with your altimeter so you can see
this big step as it passes over the
cliff and the green is the bomber
altitude which you can see there has
this little dip which is reflected a
little different there that's because as
the plane goes through its pitch to go
actually dragged onto the runway the
altitude the Berkeley has been taken out
the position of the sensor changes that
will go through a some change in the
reports taos - which doesn't matter as
they're reporting it because the parts
are looking at that particular point
they're looking at the runway and then
velocity one's ground to move one is the
airspeed which is a meaningful
difference ground to B is what you need
to plot air speeds what the aircraft
needs to know to say if it fires too
fast or too slow you'll pull out the sky
which is always inconvenient and the
reason why we have to have them separate
is because you can have different winds
so if you've got the wind going directly
into you'll have a low ground speed but
a high air speed if you've got the wind
at our wind so it's pushing it you'll
have a higher ground speed and
potentially allowing a speed so working
on difference and understanding why and
making sure the things will check with
each other is part of the content so how
did this so this is cars doing detect
early I mentioned before done working
with the spherical coordinate frame is a
pain but there's the Geo point library
and it's absolutely fantastic because it
can do spherical distance calculations
because this is a shortest route between
two points in the Cartesian space is a
straight line on the surface of a sphere
or geoid as I believe the photographer's
like to refer to it it's actually has
what's called a great circle distance so
by using this Vincente distance function
we can actually get for the actual GOI
with the real notes but on field the
actual distance traveled so by combining
this with the magnetic heading of the
aircraft and the ground speed of the
aircraft we can actually do
much better trajectory plotting by doing
essentially respectively by for each
frame taking the magnetic heading and
the ground to be to combine them using
this great circle function to actually
plot where they went because we know it
touched down the wrong way and we've
worked out to some reasonable accuracy
they touch down at the port in the wrong
way so we can work for them back to them
plot the ground track of their aircraft
so there we go we can plot the where
they went so you can see we've got this
little tweak count which I've there's a
little bit of HTML and a little iframe
and it'll pop up within the photo
library I will try to get that code so
if it's fantastic see so you can see
with words so it's 307 meters after the
endpoint that you actually touchdown
which is a little bit deep and then the
prison will be able to reconstruct the
trajectory using that geo par library
you can see that the blue which is the
fitted is much closer and in terms of
general shape is actually a much a very
good match for the underlying taxiway
and you can see I've got these yellow
carrots to show where the vs. were
deployed and stowed again and if we go
to the little motor control this is why
and the other thing is the combination
of the over PI library and the folding
reliably and GFN it's absolutely
fantastic cause you can have any other
layers so I can actually have these
markers and this is actually the
precision approach point indicator
lights so you can have all this other
cotton weave very good context to try to
understand what's happening why and you
can turn on off when you don't need it
folium is fantastic
so the end result was that we've got
quite reasonable
looting Square improvement by doing this
translation imagine the terrain which
meant that we got quite a nice
distribution it's it's not necessary a
normal distribution but you can see
we've got anywhere from landing short by
about 200 meters to landing long by
about 300 and yes it's nice is it
actually no idea this is where we get to
one of the other things is that I've now
derived from flight data which is
relatively low frequency and as we know
has some variables with some very blue
accuracy some estimate for how long or
short a particular distribution of
aircraft landed a different way but we
need to go a little bit further than
that what we need to do is we need to
have some understanding of what's the
error in this calculation and does this
work for other airfields so what we do
is we need to go from A to D case where
we've just gotten terrain for the
approach to one particular one way to
three D where we can generate it from
the actual digital frame map and then do
an automated generation where we've got
the digital surface map and a district
or a map from people that Ordnance
Survey and very kindly from people like
NASA who did what's called SRTM there
was the shuttle radar topography mission
where they had a radio altimeter might
slide the aircraft in the payload Bay of
the shuttle and they just orbited the
earth and scanned the whole thing it
looks a little bit like a waffle because
there's bits that were missed out so
there's the gap between the Suede's
where the shuttle flew over and got
relatively but it's actually very good
data it's about it's not the finest
detail but it's quite good if you have
some money you can get the Ordnance
Survey look if you very fine detailed
that with five meter interval points
which is very good data and they've very
lucky they give me some of that but then
you have to actually deal with it and if
you're getting
fine detail data
starting to use other things like glass
so for that we use the coderre library
which is yeah it's a Python library that
cool supersize focus I don't need to
touch any of that so I can start using
the Geo Pender's functions for geometry
collections where I've taken the
taxiways which I got from OpenStreetMap
using the over PI library and I can
buffer them to get all the area around
them and then I can subtract all the
different tax rate cycling I did for
each taxiway individually and now I can
use those as a filter using about of get
only those points when they're digital
frame map for example for this tax rate
but also for the because I'm storing the
flight trajectory as a Geo Jason I can
also use that as a filter think about to
get only those digital terrain map
points within the footprint of that geo
Jason plus a little buffer so I can then
do much more further backing and to
write matching so I could adds a little
bit filly to install but it's a very
useful library for working with this
very high volume digital terrain so this
is what I'm due to do that so now that
I've got a more ways to confuse
everything by having high matt sector
this is what i'm doing to do validation
on the other end so i'm using those
taxiways as my validation method by
seeing how well the ground trajectory
matches up with the taxiways i can then
do a comparison and again using a very
similar translation but also including
some rotation i can work out how well
the aircraft taxing on the actual
airport matches with the known locations
of the taxiways which unlike the
aircraft don't move around and they
don't tend to change very often so it's
it's quite a good dataset and again it
we get it from the open student library
and again we use a shaping and it's
absolutely fantastic so this is the most
autonomous and possibly one more and
test aircraft ever created for the
pelican and that was a brief one do a
flight data analysis
using that poison and trying to work out
where the hell we actually landed thank
you very much
do we have any questions I can imagine
that your data gets incredibly noisy so
are you using different Python processes
to kind of scrub that data or can you go
a little bit more detail about how
you're scrubbing those sure I mean at
the end the day the data ends up in an
intermediary form so depend upon your
preference you can handle it like an SQL
data base frame where you can do like
filtering for and window averaging I
don't tend to because the although there
is a lot of noise the noise is all we've
got the stuff we want to remove is the
gross artifacts where it goes from being
sniffing on the wrong way and not moving
at all so it's just stuck at the gate -
according data in the database of like
Mac - I'm not kidding I found
I thought pointer data where a 737
believes it's going back - it's just not
real it's just because of an integer
overflow or it's where there's been so
interleaving between two particular
variables but weren't expected to change
it by the same entity at the same time
and so it doesn't matter if these two
collide or they collide didn't there we
go
some of the translators that go from the
binary format to CSV or to SQL or
whatever your flavor they can notice
that some of them are better at handing
that than others it's not necessary
anymore one one's a better at hand at
others but it's an ongoing process I
have a little bit of work to write a
Python library to actually do that but
because the logical framework is a
copyrighted thing it kind of makes it
more difficult because I can't
distribute the LFL so it's I am the only
people that I actually look at this data
with the logical frame house and I can't
get other people to help me with it
because they don't have the data
I was I was interested in that library
you had for her interacting with
OpenStreetMap I was wondering if that's
open source yeah it's one of many things
you can just list all by pip perfect to
be compatible Oh
overplay is fantastic well actually I
didn't show you the thing but so this is
why I was talking about with using tax
ways to develop because I can select
only those points where that was
actually interacted with the buffer
around the taxiway so I can then match
for individual tax ways sub-segments
within with a bit of any amount where
you can just do a translational rotation
yeah hope you don't mind a response to
the first question so there's lots of
different types of invalid data that are
found within parameters so rate of
change algorithms to look at whether or
not it's changing faster than you'd
expect
minimum max limits on parameters
correlation tests with other parameters
so you can see if it fits an expected
gradient with another parameter and
there's various other things but there's
Eric forty-nine signals and all types
things which aren't valid days are would
completely throw off certain algorithms
yeah there's there's there is tons of
stuff you can do to make it look pretty
but I I try to forget that it's it's fat
data because you can make data look very
pretty and give you only valid stuff and
when you put it as an input to an
algorithm you do want to do that but
when I'm plotting it for my own use to
try and understand what's happening in
where the air is coming from
I want to see it warts and all but yes
your archive right there are some there
are a lot of tools for employment
especially the sideway another question
is there no scope for using like the
airports radar system for altitude well
some of you may have seen flightradar24
there's various websites online but
they're one of them where you can see
where the aircraft are in real-time what
nearly all time so that uses what's
called secondary radar where it's an
alias B transponder which is on the
aircraft itself and gets illuminated by
the very light every time it gets pulsed
it will respond saying I'm this aircraft
or I'm going in this direction to this
to such a such a destination Airport I'm
at this altitude at this speed at this
heading it's great and that's what
you'll get out as a kind of a live feed
but the reason those web sites are able
to display data is because they actually
would call it live by just listening in
on the radio unfortunately when it's
logged by national entities they don't
share and the tiny air lines are
fantastic people lovely people
they don't share either in fact they're
more difficult to get data out of the
national entities the reason we have
that bait set of toys because that aired
I'm known on what plates so we can't
infringe the rights and the own images
of the pilots we have any other
questions what were the safety
conclusions of your work then what did
you learn about pilot behavior I think
the most important safety conclusion is
that pilots are human with that care no
incidents they should have done what's
called total which is takeoff go-around
which is basically we're gonna try this
again Matt but Togo isn't necessarily
always the safest option and that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to
create a database that we can do base
level statistical analysis of all
different approaches all the different
times they nearly went off the runway
because at the moment we can't detect
that this is the car tools we need to
enable that basic research into all the
times they nearly did something but
because nothing happened there was no
need to report it so we don't have
about whether it was good or bad we
don't know how close they were to
something happening near miss report is
getting better but it's limited in terms
of what's there at the moment so this
what this is what that kind of this type
of thing will enable we have time for
one or two more questions there No okay
then I would like to thank our speaker
and you can take your belongings with
you
[Applause]